المياه هي حاجة أساسية للغاية يجب على كل شخص
في العالم أن نبدأ
المياه فيها جيدًا حتى نجعل
الماء الملوث مثل هذا نظيفًا
وآمنًا للشرب مثل هذا ،
لذلك قررنا حسنًا كيف يمكننا مساعدة هؤلاء
الأشخاص ولكن بطريقة مستدامة  قابل للتطوير
وله تأثير إيجابي على المناخ أيضًا
[موسيقى
] ، يعمل الفلتر بمفهوم الترشيح الطبيعي ،
إنه مثل وعاء
معروف بالفعل في الثقافة المصرية
لسنوات عديدة ، نستخدم طينًا
وموارد طبيعية مختلفة في المرحلة الأولى
و  نأخذ ذلك إلى المكبس
الهيدروليكي ونبدأ في تشكيل القدر ثم
نبدأ في وضعه في الفرن
الكهربائي وبعد ذلك يتم معالجة القدر
بجزيئات الفضة النانوية لإزالة
جميع الشوائب والطعم والرائحة
القديمة والبكتيريا
هذه هي خطوة الترشيح  في حد ذاته حيث
إذا كان هناك أي شوائب
وبكتيريا تبقى بالداخل وستخرج المياه النظيفة
من هذا المنفذ ،
وهدفنا النهائي هو منح الجميع
إمكانية الوصول إلى الماء النظيف  إيه ، وهو
حقهم الأساسي
[موسيقى].